ces grillons ne sont pas les vedettes de
l'insectarium de montréal
ils sont plutôt destinées à relever la
saveur d'une nouvelle bière noire à la
microbrasserie lion bleu d'alma on ne
lésine pas sur les quantités 5 kg
donneront le goût de béthune et de pain
grillé à la stop grillant on a vraiment
sonné chez les grillons avec la grille
on est allé chercher les petites notes
de noisette un petit côté de nos
intéressante qui est là et puis on ose
espérer que la le côté protéines et du
grillon va aider à la venturi n'hésitez
née d'un défi qu'a lancée en tomo dsp
une ferme d'élevage des grillons de
saint-pascal à la baleine avait appelé
de rivière ouelle la microbrasserie à
développer la recette brasse et au lion
bleu les trois entreprises avaient soif
des produits surprenants
on voulait aussi tout enfant apprend
quelque chose de fly et mais de le faire
de façon si sérieusement à c'est ce que
l'on fait toujours sortir les gens un
peu de leur zone de confort le site
inévitable les wc pénates faire une
place à table
pourtant ils sont riches en protéines et
en vitamines leur élevage est aussi
beaucoup plus d'écologie qu'est
l'élevage animal
encore faut-il réussir à faire tomber
les barrières aux logiques
ça fait partie du défi mais justement
c'est qu'on avait deux conflits aussi
que si on veut mettre de la vaste de
pratiques l'alimentaire mais la
meilleure façon de le valoriser c'est de
le présenter via des restaurateurs rio
des compagnies transformateurs alors
voilà on se lance bon appétit
ce qu'on retient
le brasseur du lion bleu est confiant de
charme et le palais des plus sceptiques
sa voix quand même la faim devant ce
défi à ton ami à tassara ta famille on
le sait dessus je pense que sa santé en
vue d'une boisson originale pour
surprendre vous éviter dans le temps des
fêtes
les premières bières seront disponibles
dans moins d'un mois dans l'une des deux
microbrasseries et en épicerie i6000 sa
part a dit reds au canada alma